[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
for more than two centuries the u.s
senate has required the support of at
least 60 senators
before they pass major pieces of
legislation that makes for a cumbersome
system it requires compromise and
patience it delays the passage of laws
but it has endured through the centuries
despite
leadership of the body at times senate
has been controlled by republicans other
times it's been controlled by democrats
but that standard the standard of 60
votes often referred to as the
filibuster rule has never changed we've
had it since 1806 when thomas jefferson
was the president why is that it's not
just because u.s senators tend to be
pompous and mindlessly wedded to
tradition though obviously they are
it's because this is a democracy sober
people know that before you make
big changes to a country you had better
be certain that a large
majority of your citizens support what
you're doing that's the principle behind
our entire system of government
and whatever you do as a lawmaker you'd
better be thoughtful about it absolutely
certain that what you're doing is
wise and won't hurt your grandchildren
in ways that you haven't bothered to
think through
and that's why for 214 years we've
required a super majority in the senate
it's not just an arcane piece of senate
procedure
it's central to the way the country
works but what would happen if suddenly
people with very different attitudes
took control
of our system what if these new people
didn't care about the wisdom or
long-term consequences of the things
they did
what if they didn't believe in democracy
what if they considered debate
and persuasion winning people over
pointless
even immoral and instead intended to
rule by force
what if all these people cared about was
power well people like that of course
would hate the filibuster rule
it would be an obstacle in their path to
total control and they would be
desperate to eliminate it
they'd never admit that out loud
needless to say they'd never be directed
by anything
in fact they would despise clear precise
english and they would punish
anyone who dared to speak it people like
this would instead rely on feline
misdirection to get what they wanted
they'd lie about everything boldly and
without shame
they would denounce their enemies for
the very sins they themselves were
committing
if they wanted to turn america into a
one-party state for example a state that
they alone control they wouldn't say
that out loud
they would instead accuse anyone who
opposed that goal of quote
partisanship and they wouldn't even
smile as they said it
watch when the democrats have the white
house again
if mitch mcconnell tries to do what he
did to president obama and put
small-minded partisanship ahead of
solving the massive problems in this
country
then we should get rid of the filibuster
[Applause]
small-minded partisanship well joe biden
served
in the u.s senate for decades he always
supported the filibuster
when he was there now biden appears to
agree with elizabeth warren
if republicans won't obey the newly
ascended democratic party
biden said recently we'll just cut them
out of the conversation
chuck schumer of course is on board too
former vice president biden recently
suggested that he would be open to
supporting eliminating the filibuster
uh if republicans obstruct his agenda
where do you stand on that are you more
receptive to
taking a look at doing that job number
one is for us to get the majority
we don't take anything for granted but
it's looking better and better and once
we get the majority we'll discuss it in
our caucus nothing's off the table
nothing's off the table in other words
the
second we take control and that could be
soon we're getting rid of the
filibuster so how do you do that exactly
how do you justify
on what grounds do you change a system
that has worked
demonstrably well for centuries
will you justify the same way you
justify tearing down ancient statues
that
until last week weren't even
controversial you claim they represent
bigotry
they're already doing that last month
the atlantic denounced the filibuster as
quote another monument to white
supremacy
on sunday faithful democratic party
lackey ron brownstein wrote a piece
arguing that getting rid of the
filibuster
is quote a civil rights issue because
apparently democrats used the filibuster
60 years ago
to slow the passage of civil rights
legislation which by the way passed
anyway and therefore republicans are
bigots for wanting to keep the
filibuster
following that that's the level of
debate currently underway among smart
people in washington
it's moronic but it's also transparent
that doesn't mean it's not working
though
it is the filibuster could soon be gone
there's a lot at stake in this
conversation it's not obscure it's real
and it's practical
with the last check and balance gone
there will be no limit to the ways the
democratic party can remake
the country in their first few months in
power
we don't have to guess about their
planes they've told us what they plan to
do
and without a filibuster they will be
fully capable of doing it
turn gun owners into criminals let
actual criminals go free
ban all criticism of their ideas and
behavior
crush independent media voices like this
channel pass the lunatic green new deal
which does nothing for the environment
and does an awful lot for their control
of the country
pack the senate by making dc a state
pack the supreme court by simply packing
it adding more justices
and just to make certain they never lose
another election
add tens of millions of foreign
nationals
to u.s voter rolls they will call that
immigration
reform they'll dare you to call it
something else they'll charge you with
hate speech
if you try you think they won't do all
that
why wouldn't they do all that their
voters their core voters are demanding
they do all that and with no filibuster
they can
because no one can stop them